first of all i
hope you and your family have been doing
well in this crazy time
thank you steve same to you with all the
announcements you made recently about
disney plus and uh the mcu how
how far out have you guys actually
planned
uh the mcu at this point even if you
haven't announced
what um what what is coming in those
years
to varying degrees of specificity it's
always about five
five to six years out versus what we
we've announced so whatever that takes
us to got it um
i think a lot of people have wondered
how involved you are
in star wars stuff so i'm just going to
ask how involved are you in star wars
stuff besides the
movie that you're producing not at all
got it moving on moving on to the next
thing
um i loved what i've seen so far of one
division
um i just want to uh thank you for
taking such a big swing with it
um but i am curious uh a lot of people
talk about the episode lengths of mcu
stuff so i
i want to know how long are episodes
seven eight and nine
of wand division uh they all
vary like like uh
uh many streaming series you're not tied
into
you know programming that has to start
and stop
so so it it very even those first three
you saw
vary slightly um that variation
grows a little bit towards the end got
um with the news that loki might be
getting a season two
have you guys thought about doing a one
division season two or is it called
doctor strange two well it will always
it will always
vary um uh where the disney plus
series continues on through the mcu
in the case of um
juan division most immediately as we've
already announced yes multiverse of
madness
with wanda and also uh also captain
marvel two
for monica rambo tiana paris's character
uh is where we will see them uh next
got it um have you figured out even if
you obviously haven't announced it yet
but have you figured out
how you're going to bring mutants into
the mcu and is it part of the multiverse
or is it still
beyond the five-year thing it has it has
um
been heavily discussed as you might
imagine um
uh and we uh and we
and we have a good feeling of where it's
going and when it's going but that will
all remain to be seen
got it in your mind have you cast who
you want to be wolverine
or is it still too far out no
got it uh with the disney stuff
the with the disney plus series that you
guys are doing
do you envision stuff like hawkeye and
miss marvel as
multi-season series or are they all
just being designed as like a
one-and-done kind of a thing
no it's a it's a it's a combination some
are uh
um i mean look at look at our movies
in the past there's always maybe maybe
it'll be characters appearing in other
people's things maybe it'll be another
version of uh
another storyline with that main
character uh it all
it all varies based on based on the
storyline got it um do you is there any
chance that
charlie cox could be back as daredevil
or do you consider what happened with
netflix
almost like an alternate universe you
know i look at
anything that has happened before uh
whether it's our movies
whether it's marvel entertainment tv
series in particular obviously the
comics
video games cartoons all of it is um
is uh um available as inspiration
uh for uh for uh the future of marvel
that's the way the comics have worked
for
80 years so so uh uh
we'll see got it i think a lot of people
really loved charlie in that role
and are hopeful that he can find a way
back
i got it i'm not gonna get any more um
how do you guys decide
which characters are better suited for
like a tv series
and which are a movie for example miss
marvel is a disney plus series
but blade is going to be a movie it
really is about the story the individual
stories we want to tell
um and a bit informed by by the bigger
picture
we we knew that we want to introduce ms
marvel first and her family and all of
her great supporting characters in her
origin
in a disney plus uh
long form series and then bring her into
captain marvel 2.
um there will be some times where the
opposite
happens um a character is introduced in
a movie and brought on to
a disney plus series so really just
varies based on uh
based on the story or the genre that we
want to explore
got it with secret invasion that almost
feels like that could be a movie or a
series of movies
and you're bringing it to disney plus
will that show
have a bigger scale and scope than some
of the others
um i'm just curious because that
storyline could be
huge yes i mean
you know we're we're interested in the
in the
paranoia political paranoia aspect of
secret invasion
and really showcasing the the stars
with nick fury and ben mendelsohn two
amazing actors that you'd want to have
in any series
and we're very lucky to have them for
that um
that's the sort of primary focus of that
and of course it will tie into other
things and and and the scrolls
in ways you haven't seen before um but
yes
anything could be anything could be
anything
my wise words um uh orson welles is on
your shirt
uh yeah cool um
uh but we wanted to do that as a uh as a
series
because it would allow us to do
something different than we've done
before
got it uh where are you in the
development process of deadpool 3
and will it be rated r it will be rated
r
and we um
are working on a script right now and
ryan's overseeing a script
right now so it's it's it's begun i
think that was announced wasn't it yeah
i think so but i guess i'm curious
when do you think it could be in front
of cameras could it be in front of
cameras this year
or there's no chance uh
it will not be this year ryan is a very
busy um
very successful actor we've got we've
got um
a number of things we've already
announced that we have to now make um
but it it it's exciting for it to have
begun
again a very different type of
character in the mcu and ryan is a force
of nature which is just awesome to see
him uh
bring that character to life with um
falcon and the winter soldier and loki
and hawkeye um do you envision those
shows being
30 minutes each or because a lot of the
disney plus series seem to be around 30
minutes each
and i'm just curious if any of these
things are ever going to always be like
an
hour or 50 minute episodes we're looking
a little differently we're looking at is
developing them
as either six hours six
hour episodes or um you know ten
nine or ten half hour episodes but
that so for instance one division
started that way
and a falcon winner as a as a 30 minutes
but because it's streaming it's disney
plus
and and the rules have blurred over the
years
yes some can be 23 minutes some could be
um uh much longer than that um
but she-hulk for instance is being
developed
as um as 10 30-minute episodes some will
be longer and some will be shorter
loki falconer soldier is being developed
as six
uh uh um you know 40 50
minute episodes god it's because i was
also curious with like moon knight
um you know how is it is it basically
everything you're doing around six hours
yes the thing about one division is that
i love the
commercials that are in each episode and
i'm curious
how much is in those commercials should
fans be paying attention to that provide
context to the bigger picture and how
much are those commercials
sort of like like i guess how
significant are the commercials well i
think
it's a i think it's intriguing in my
opinion and i
and i hope everybody has has varying
opinions and theories
but it is it is a nice combination of
both it fits into the
it fits into the genre and the tone of
uh
of the period of television that we're
playing with um in a way
it also um has subtextual meetings
some some of which are clear than others
a a
device with a spark industry's logo and
a beeping red button
uh may mean more to people who know
wanda's past
uh from the mcu uh than other things but
yes they are they all
i hope are a joyful combo of both of
those things
yeah um i i i'm gonna stop there and i'm
gonna say listen it's really hard to
talk about one division when i've only
seen three episodes
it's like and that's like just to be
clear like i want to talk about one
division but i want to talk about it
once i've actually seen the whole thing
and can then start asking like specific
questions
do you know what i mean it's really
steve we've talked about this in the
past
occasionally not often but once in a
while we would have this conversation
before you'd seen the movie
and that was always that's always i
never liked that
um there's no choice with tv it's coming
out week to week it's the way it is